[Musique]
on est vendredi 9 janvier 2015 aux
alentours de 17 heures il fait beau je
suis à pied sur une bretelle d'accès du
boulevard périphérique parisien avec des
camarades
et j'ai une porte à ouvrir
alors j'imagine que vous vous dites que
mon histoire n'est pas très original que
vous faites ça tous les soirs en
rentrant chez vous que ça ne demande pas
de capacités particulières
pourtant ma porte fait assez spécial
d'abord elle est fait pour contrarier
les cambrioleurs puisque elle s'ouvre en
tirant pour pas qu'on puisse la défense
et l ess me blinder elle dispose d'une
barre de sécurité en renfort ensuite et
surtout derrière
et un terroriste il a des armes de
guerre de l'explosif il a déjà tué
quatre personnes et menace d'exécuter 26
otages dont une femme enceinte en plus
de tout ça partout il ya des
journalistes qui filme tous nos faits et
gestes et on est déjà très fatigué parce
qu'on a passé les deux derniers jours à
traquer deux autres terroristes coupable
de la tuerie de charlie hebdo pour
ouvrir cette porte j'ai pas les clés
mais j'ai de l'explosif
vous l'avez tous compris
on est face à l'hyper cacher de la porte
de vincennes
je fais partie des équipes du raid on va
donner l'assaut dans les minutes qui
suivent dont camarades et moi on va
ouvrir la porte de service à l'explosif
alors
au quotidien la vie y aurait deux
ressemblent un peu à des vacances ont
fait de l'hélicoptère du parachutisme du
tir d' escalade mais régulièrement comme
ce 9 janvier 2015 on fait quelque chose
de très particulier on se met à
l'épreuve
alors 7 cette mise à l'épreuve j'avais
déjà connu la version sportive puisque
j'étais en équipe de france de judo
pendant cinq ans j'ai 14 sélections
internationales j'ai notamment remporté
le tournoi de paris bercy qui est au
judo ce que roland garros au tennis
je suis ceinture noire 6e dan mais j'ai
ensuite vécu la version plus radicale
puisque j'ai intégré la colonne d'assaut
du raid l'unité d'élite de la police
nationale pendant vingt ans j'ai
participé à plusieurs centaines
d'interventions et d'arrestations dans
les derniers rangs les plus
emblématiques et en colonne à l'hyper
cacher les terrasses parisiennes le
bataclan saint-denis 21 mars 2012 dans
la ferme ira à toulouse le terrorisme a
frappé de deux balles une balle dans
l'épaule une balle dans le casque a fait
enrager cérébrale on m'a remis la légion
d'honneur pour faits d'armes
s'est mise à l'épreuve dont je vous
parle on deux aspects
la première c'est que on risque nos vies
donc on peut pas rentrer le soir en
disant à son épouse
tient au fait ma chérie je t'ai pas dit
mais aujourd'hui j'ai failli mourir
parce qu'elle nous répondrait mais t'as
pensé aux enfants tu as pensé à moi donc
résultat
j'ai reçu plusieurs médailles de
l'institution sans en parler à ma
famille pour ne pas inquiéter
n'en parlez pas à ma femme
la deuxième version
c'est que à un moment t on
met à l'épreuve toutes nos compétences
au raid on peut pas se reposer sur ses
lauriers parce que les balles n'ont pas
d'émotions elle ne respecte pas le
statut ou le passé à des gens qu'elle
frappe
seul compte le présent
on n'existe que par notre dernier acte
est souvent la partie est serrée entre
le statut du héros et statut de zéro il
n'y a pas l'épaisseur d'une feuille de
cigarette
aujourd'hui je vais vous
je vais vous partager quelques
procédures que mes camarades et moi
avons mis en place pour
pour affronter ces épreuves alors ces
procédures sont universels elle vous
serviront à affronter vos propres
épreuves
la première chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il existe deux zones
d'évolution bien distinctes la zone de
confort et la zone de haute pression et
elles sont régies par des règles
totalement différente alors mettons-nous
d'abord à la place d'un individu normal
dans cette zone de confort
tout va bien au niveau de vos habiletés
mentales vos capacités physiques
techniques psychiques sont stables le
flux et l'information l'intensité des
informations que vous avez à traiter
sont modérés les difficultés que vous
avez à gérer entre dans le cadre de vos
compétences vous êtes tranquilles comme
actuellement
mais quand se présente une épreuve
tout ce bel équilibre s'effondre vos
capacités physiques psychiques
techniques sont négativement impactés
vous perdez vos moyens et pourquoi
réagissez-vous ainsi et bien parce que
vos habiletés mentales de zone de
confort ne sont pas suffisamment aiguisé
pour fonctionner en zone de haute
pression
il va donc falloir vous fabriquez une
deuxième qui ramid d'habileté mental une
pyramide rouge spécifique à vos propres
zone de haute pression cette pyramide
est fait avec les mêmes éléments que la
pyramide verte mais régler différemment
si vous voulez bien je vais vous aider à
effectuer les bons réglages
alors d'abord
observons les réflexes les côtés
positifs et négatifs en côté positif on
a les réactions physiologiques points
devant l'hyper cacher on va avoir les
jambes qui tremblent qui flageolent un
peu et bien c'est c'est la nature qui
intensifient les influx nerveux pour
nous rendre plus réactif physiquement on
va transpirer pour anticiper le futur
échauffement
notre sens va quitter les organes
inutile au combat et à la fuite pour
alimenter les muscles locomoteur
résultat on va voir un noeud à l'estomac
la gorge sèche c'est parce que le sens
quitte la fonction digestive certains
vont avant avoir envie d'aller aux
toilettes c'est parce que le sens quitte
la vessie on va avoir un peu de chair de
poule pour que nos poils se dressent
pour comparer ce plus impressionnant
comme le font les chiens les chiens les
ours
tous ses réflexes il faut pas s'en
inquiéter parce qu'ils sont là pour nous
rendre service c'est la première règle
il faut accepter son stress
également nos réflexes
ont été aiguisés pendant les millions
d'années de notre évolution résultat on
les a dans la peau c'est pour ça que
quand on a une face à une grosse
difficulté on dit toujours que faut
aller chercher des solutions non
seulement de nos têtes mais aussi dans
nos tripes pour conserver tous ses
atouts il va falloir résister à au
confort de la vie moderne qui nous
ramolli physiquement il faut se
densifier il faut entretenir sa
rusticité par exemple en poussant un peu
la voiture pour faire un peu plus de
sport en prenant quelques douches
froides en mangeant un peu moins
intellectuellement il faut rester vif et
un petit peu sauvage si vous acceptez de
rentrer dans des moules vous allez
devenir une tarte si vous acceptez les
barrières vous allez devenir un mouton
si vous acceptez de rester bloqué dans
un coin dans une boîte vous pourrez plus
déployer vos ailes alors malheureusement
les réflexes ont aussi des des points
négatifs
d'abord on va pas pouvoir les développer
parce qu'ils relèvent de l'ine on dit
toujours on fera pas un mulet un cheval
de course ou encore mieux que quelle que
soit la longueur de la piste on fera pas
décoller un cochon
également nos réflexes on va pas
toujours pouvoir les contrôler parce que
en m'approchant l'hyper cacher si
quelque chose me fait très peur je
risque d'avoir un cri réflexes ou
d'avoir un sursaut réflexes et je vais
me faire repérer
également nos réflexes ne sont pas
toujours mises à jour par rapport à nos
problématiques actuelles
par exemple aurait dit on va se méfier
nos réflexes par exemple on va toujours
mettre le doigt tendu sur la carcasse de
larmes et pas sur la détente pour ne pas
faire un tir réflexe
donc en règle générale on va plutôt
essayer de se créer des automatismes
c'est plus fiable parce que ça se
travaille on a quatre types
d'automatismes et fonctionnent tous de
la même manière on répète et il s'ancre
dans nos têtes on a d'abord les
automatismes physique et
technico-tactique aurait on va
s'entraîner à tirer avec nos armes
jusqu'à ce que ce geste soit aussi
fluide et naturel que d'amener sa
cuillère à la bouche vous devez faire la
même chose avec vos propres gestes
professionnels
ensuite on a les automatismes de penser
sachez que là aussi si vous choisissez
une pensée et que vous la répéter eh
bien vous creuser un sillon neuronale
qui va fixer cette pensée dans votre
tête et la rendre prioritaire sur toutes
les autres pensées avec cette méthode et
bien vous pouvez choisir vos pensées
comme on choisit ses vêtements
on a encore les automatismes émotionnel
au raid on va prioriser les émotions dit
professionnel et repousser les émotions
plus sociétale plus futiles par exemple
je vais conserver la peur de prendre une
balle parce que c'est cette peur qui va
me faire ajuster mon bouclier mais je
vais rejeté la peur d'être critiqué par
mon chef parce que c'est pas une une
émotion strictement opérationnels
strictement lié à l'action on a ensuite
les les automatismes d'adaptation au
stress est bien là face à l'hyper cachet
à une équipe du raid va être va avoir
les automatismes d'avancé là où la
majorité de la population aurait plutôt
le réflexe elle de reculer alors
travailler vos automatismes va vous
apporter plusieurs avantages
un gain de temps d'abord parce que c'est
plus rapide qu'une action qui serait lié
à un processus de réflexion
c'est important parce que par exemple en
judo une seconde c'est le temps de
prendre un balayage en intervention de
police une kalachnikov de terroristes
satire 600 coups par minute ça veut dire
qu'en une seconde il ya dix coups de feu
tirés ça veut dire dix morts potentiel
également nos automatismes vont nous
faire économiser de l'espace de
réflexion parce qu'on va automatiser le
prévisible pour laisser ensuite on aura
ainsi plus de place dans le cerveau le
jour j pour gérer l'imprévisible la
gestion d'incertitude c'est un impératif
en sport c'est un impératif au raid et
c'est un impératif générale dans toutes
les entreprises
également les automatismes vont nous
rendre plus plus stable c'est à dire
qu'avec eux on va éviter tous les
conflits internes liées aux réflexions
et aux émotions et aux pensées comme ça
on agira de la même manière à lundi
matin en forme et à vendredi soir
fatigué on aura plus de sang-froid plus
de stabilité dans notre prise de
décision
attention les automatismes nécessitent
les conditions identiques entre le
moment où on le construit et le moment
où on la réalise ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir s'entraîner cet impératif dans
les conditions de l'épreuve à vitesse
égale
difficulté égale intensité égale à
prévisibilité égale stress égale
dernier habiletés mentales
la réflexion alors il faut faire la
différence entre la réflexion
traditionnelle qui fonctionne très bien
en zone de confort et la réflexion
adapté à la crise qu'on utilise sous les
balles
la réflexion traditionnel prend trop de
place dans la tête elle ressemble à un
livre avec beaucoup trop de pages
beaucoup trop de détails et ça
fonctionne pas on peut pas aller en
intervention de police ou en compétition
de judo en compulsant un livre si si je
devais vous faire un cours mois sur la
libération d'otages eh bien je mettrai
sur mon écran mentale 20 30 feuilles
détaillé et je vous parlerai pendant
deux trois heures de la libération
d'otages ça c'est la réflexion
traditionnel mais si j'étais rappelé sur
une prise d'otages je serais obligé
d'enlever les 20-30 feuilles précise
pour mettre à la place une seule feuille
avec dessus seulement quelques points
clés quelques points quelques points
balises quelques points de concentration
ça c'est la réflexion adapté à la crise
c'est un pense-bête synthétique que vous
devez vous construire vous même avec
cette méthode eh bien vous pourrez gérer
plusieurs problèmes à la fois
la réflexion traditionnel également être
trop lente pour fonctionner en zone de
crise si tu réfléchis en zone de crise
tu réfléchis tu es mort
pourquoi et bien parce que un événement
de zones de crise c'est davantage chargé
en difficulté davantage chargé en en
intensité davantage chargé en
imprévisibilité temps à charger en
rapidité c'est à dire que quand il passe
si vous y réfléchissez quand vous
trouvez la solution c'est trop tard il
est passé pas un pin pin d'alep pris
trois balles il se passe la même chose
quand vous vous disputez avec quelqu'un
et que c'est seulement deux heures après
que vous trouvez la bonne répartie trop
tard vous avez été trop lents
la réflexion c'est bon avant l'action
c'est-à-dire au briefing c'est bon au
débriefing mais en tueur de crise la
réflexion nuit à l'action la ici il faut
agir si on veut bien
synthétisé je vous dirais qu'on ne peut
rien réussir en restant enfermé dans sa
zone de confort les habiletés mentales
de zone de confort ce qu'il faut c'est
s'exposer progressivement aux épreuves
pour se re programmer et pour adapter
nos habiletés mentales à la pression
c'est darwin qui le dit et dit celui qui
survit mais on pourrait dire celui qui
performent
c'est pas le plus fort
c'est pas le plus intelligent non plus
mais c'est celui qui se le mieux
s'adapter aux changements nous le 9
janvier 2015 mes camarades et moi on a
su s'adapter à la haute pression notre
plus belle récompense et un otage qui
nous a cité le talmud celui qui sauf une
seule vie sauve le monde entier eh bien
nous ce jour là en empêchant le
terroriste d'altérer nos habiletés
mentales et bien à sauver 26 fois
l'humanité
26 et demi même si on compte la femme
enceinte on a fait ce pourquoi on
s'entraîne tous les jours sauver des
vies à vous de faire pareil en utilisant
ces mêmes principes pour performer sous
stress merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]